every bit of that Playa is full of
mercury arsenic selenium it's full of it
the largest impact of course will be
dust the cost of not to anything could
be in the tens of billions of dollars we
are screwed because 20 years ago not
enough people were thinking 20 years
ahead little by little the Salton Sea is
disappearing California's largest inland
body of water used to cover where I'm
standing but right now it's receded so
far behind me that I can barely see it
and disaster looms on the horizon toxic
dust is getting kicked up and the
communities nearby are suffering from
alarming rates of asthma and kids are
some of the most vulnerable
you let that C die we're gonna die with
it
this is not a joke this area already
looks like Mad Max meets Timothy Leary
gutted communities burping mounds of mud
and piles of dead fish along the beaches
but it didn't always look this bad in
1905 and 1906 the Salton Sea was created
by accident when the banks of the
Colorado River broke and flooded it at
the time people thought that the lake
was just going evaporate and disappear
but what ended up happening was that it
was fed by water like this that was
runoff from farms in the nearby area
back then water was so plentiful it
seemed like a good idea to turn a desert
into farmland today farmers still flood
their fields and agriculture has grown
into a billion dollar a year industry
the water also drew people
it's hard to imagine now but in the 50s
and 60s the sea drew more people than
Yosemite including Hollywood glitterati
now the nearby towns have been whittled
down to diehard locals and the curious
charter boats for fishing waterskiing
just hanging out and having fun and it's
a beautiful beautiful area my first
husband and I were on our honeymoon
there was like seven restaurants and
drinking establishments on the on the
beach it was beautiful this was a really
fun place to be
if I brought my wife on our honeymoon
here she'd divorce me yeah well it
probably it looks a lot different now
oh it's extremely different the good
times could only last so long as
Southern California grew so did demand
for water from the Colorado River which
sustains cities throughout the southwest
as well as farming here in the Imperial
Valley these farms pull more water than
anyone else and the city's wanted a
bigger cut in 2003 San Diego agreed to
pay these farmers millions for their
water the deal also required the state
to come up with a plan to save the
Salton Sea problem is they haven't and
in 2017 the tap to the sea will shut off
we don't have the enclose of water that
we had before I think it is a dire
problem with time running out in
mid-2015 Governor Jerry Brown appointed
this man Bruce Wilcox to find a solution
California could afford everyone wanted
the perfect solution to the Salton Sea
and there isn't one living close to the
Salton Sea if nothing is done if no
management is his implement it is going
to be a tough deal and it's going to get
worse as the sea declines not to play
the blame game but was the state doing
enough before
I don't think anybody was doing enough
before including a stud when the wind
blows it picks up fine dust like this
from the top of the exposed Playa and
many worry that that's why the rate of
asthma here in the area is three times
higher than anywhere else in the state
experts fear that one hundred square
miles of Playa or dry lake bed could be
exposed within a decade in 2014
local students headed to the State
Capitol to urge lawmakers to take action
my little brother has asthma but the
only thing I can do is hold it
air quality gets better if it dries up
it'll be like this toxic waste line
that's all it'll be it's life or death
hospitalization rates are very very high
actually compared to the rest of
California and you know there's a
connection that when the wind starts
blowing or it is dust in the air and it
gets will come and suffering with asthma
the communities around the Salton Sea
are primarily Hispanic working-class
families largely tied to farming it's
that the Ryan asthma it seems I'm carry
more than more inhalers every year well
it's really bad and it seems to have
gotten worse it's like there's less
oxygen and I could dust
you know like clogged up my nostrils I
could hardly breathe
the particulate matter in the air is
going to increase drastically so that
exposed Playa also has chemicals like
arsenic selenium glare a mercury are
those things that will also potentially
have public health impacts definitely
because those are things that are linked
with neurological problems with immune
suppression problems with cancers as you
can see there's a string a row here of
just dead fish dozens and dozens of fish
it ended up here on the shores it's
something you see all along the edges of
the Salton Sea
so the Salton Sea is a terminal Lake
there's no exit water itself evaporates
but water brings with it a lot of salts
and other contaminants so over time it's
become increasingly salty the rising
salinity is killing off the fish and
that starts a dangerous domino effect
for over 400 species of migrating birds
who would normally stop here those words
I can have to go somewhere else the
challenge however is that we've dried up
mostly wetlands in the state of
California so there's not too many other
places for them to go where do you
recommend we go is there is there a
fairly safe but how do you save a
shrinking seed when there's not enough
water to go around I cross the border
into Mexico with a group of activists
who want to bring water back to the
Salton Sea by connecting it with the Sea
of Cortez they're looking for possible
routes this is the Laguna Salada it's a
dry lakebed in Mexico and it's covered
in this fine dust
it's what the Salton Sea looked like
before 1905 and some activists fear that
if the state of California doesn't act
fast
then the Salton Sea could look like this
again and so they've proposed a bold
plan that would take water from the Sea
of Cortez and channel it across this dry
lakebed and send it all the way down
into the Salton Sea
maybe right 7 left well that's all like
cutting okay obviously a little how the
CDC plan how long is that going to take
to become a reality if I had everybody
say go right now and take five years and
for what cost the total cost right now
are about 90 billion 90 billion dollars
yeah but the money is there where's the
money I can't tell you that
but I can tell you the money's here I
have lots of lenders I have lots of
people who are willing to participate
Dutch are willing to participate and
finance all the green houses in
agriculture so the Dutch close to Rico
there's people there willing to finance
all the solar this is hard to believe
but when you hear yourself explain and
this project does it sound realistic to
you yeah it does but then I'm looking at
it from a different side of the window
I can't help but think this is what it
must have felt like to settle the West
to look out at a desert and see so much
potential it was an era when no
infrastructure project was too big or
unreasonable it was a time for romantics
for dreaming big but today things are
much more complicated the reality is
that the future of the Salton Sea will
probably be decided here somewhere
much less romantic state assemblyman
John Boyd has proposed a very different
looking plan that seems perfectly
tailored for budget weary politicians in
Sacramento we've got a consensus
building around a plan that basically
creates a small body of water down here
runs water along the edge the plan
promises to address some of the most
pressing problems it would create
habitat for wildlife and bring tourist
dollars back to the region but no it
also says it will keep down the dust
problem is no one's sure exactly how
that will work so you're confident they
would this Swift plan that's not going
to be an issue well let me say that when
we have the full build-out we will have
a very comprehensive plan where and just
to be clear your your district is up
here right and the wind blows that way
predominantly yeah also unknown is when
any of this will get approved funded and
ultimately finished I'm optimistic that
maybe 2020 maybe 2019 maybe 2025 there's
a lot of questions out there but no it's
plan has political momentum but with all
these questions it doesn't feel like a
real solution for the unfolding disaster
in the Imperial Valley we've already
seen a migration from the Salton Sea
Bombay Beach desert shores it used to be
just lively places when the water goes
the migration will begin but that's not
always an option plenty of people here
tell me they can't afford to move or
they don't want to leave their homes for
years into California's historic drought
communities all over the state are
desperate
for water and what's happening here
around the Salton Sea could be an
alarming premonition of what's to come